how's the weather today Mike uh dance
it's a it has changed couple times
actually the windiest I think this is
the worst it's going to be all week so
the guys are out there right now Rory
McIlroy jordan Spieth Jason Day I think
they're the toughest time and the guys
get the wrong end of the draw so
advantage for Mickelson and the guys who
played late yesterday early today
Mickelson it's interesting that he was
disappointed with his 63 if I would have
said opening round Phil would you sign
up for 63 be like yeah but the fact that
he'd missed out on on the record he said
he was display city was ready to shed a
tear yet he did he did it I got equated
to Mickelson's career it's been great
heartbreaking when you look back at it
and for him that's what yesterday was I
was a great round cuz it equals the best
round the major happened 28 x 26 guys
have done it so that's all great but he
wanted the record and it's been to end
the way it happened to the putt was dead
center was going in I still think there
was something that hit right in front of
the whole dude beard slightly to the
right uh that that was a record I think
he really wanted because he's one is
majors five of them he's never been
number one in the world he's never been
a player who's got other accolades like
player of the year so to have that
record for him would have been full at
this point it's kind of thing thing
you're playing for playing for history
he's certainly not playing for the money
at this point but at age 46 doing what
he's doing is they are their parallels
here at all with net Nicholas at 46 we
won Augusta in in some in some ways
those it parallels are there because of
the number of players you haven't won uh
that weight in their lives and majors
but I think guys are in much better
shape I think it's a different time Noah
Vijay Singh still out here in still
playing he's in his early 50s McGill on
hell a menace still plays well enough to
make the cut the major and and Mickelson
has managed to schedule we know is
arthritis thing that he's dealt with but
he he's found ways to continue to
compete so I think that plus the
technology athletes careers are lasting
longer and better if they don't break
down to get injuries he's been able to
avoid the serious one so it makes him
said any kind of it makes you think
about tiger you know if if his body
wasn't breaking down the way it was
you'd still be expecting him at 40 no go
soon to be 41 still be expecting him to
be at that high level so these guys can
hang around longer I think because the
way tapping with diet workout trainers
massage ice baths herceptin stuff that
wasn't there when you were playing of
course what do you think Tigers thinking
as he watches the open I think everyone
that goes by in his mind somewhere it's
wondering if he if he can ever get back
to doing it again at that level uh you
know the mind is certainly there you
know I would think of the majors that he
doesn't play in that it burns him the
most I think it might be this one in
Augusta because I think those the two
that you need the most guile and
experience to pull off and I think
because he has so much experience at
these golf courses to be open and you
don't have to hit it 335 yards you have
to bomb it over everything and if your
wayward okay you don't have to hit
driver every time you can hit three
woods and he hit famously a very few
drivers a lot of irons in the right one
conditions and you could still have a
game plan that you can shoot 70-69 all
four days so I I would say this in the
local knowledge in Augusta which comes
with playing so many masters are the two
where he thinks somewhere in his mind if
I can get back and stay healthy to work
on my swing build on something those the
places I could I could win a major again
do it he will probably not I think those
are the places he's Mike Tirico of NBC
Sports at the Open Championship at troon
in Scotland how many times have you said
or come close to saying ESPN
you know it's always a good friend who
put the thought in your mind I
appreciate it not at all not actually
not at all not at odds I've been pretty
good so but I have I've all done Golf
Channel the first couple of days here so
it'll that has that hasn't been a
problem I don't think it'll be a problem
well they give me enough shirts with
peacock song to make sure that I don't
screw it up I actually gave the the
number for ESPN one time on this show a
couple number ya go yes yes yes and I'm
going what am i doing I but I did be
that happy I uh here's what here's what
happen if I do it you're gonna buy me
dinner only this weekend no no no when
you go to the road Mike when you go to
Rio I you know I'm not putting it in
your head in Rio unless I see you before
you know we like opening ceremonies but
I put it into your head here and I'll
buy you dinner okay yeah fair fair this
this week alone if we resist I believe
you and you buy me did you buy me dinner
in Rio do you change your tone if we if
you were doing a football game or you're
doing golf mm-hmm the difference in
inflection with excitement timing is it
very similar do you are you a different
announcer here's here's why I came
across how to handle this I remember
doing the first football game that I did
and that first full weekend after nine
luck and I was really concerned have you
this how do you react when a team scores
and I the game I happen to do was in ann
arbor where I live and it's about four
hundred ten thousand people are cheering
the way they used to cheer this happened
I'll just do what they do I'll react
accordingly if it's a muted applause
that it feels a little bit different
then I'll try to match that and I
started op adopt that philosophy when
you go to an NBA game do golf just match
what the environment is they use sounds
like a fool you're screaming do it at an
NBA game walk on golf if you're speaking
slow
all silent quiet whispers while at NBA
games going on then nobody's gonna hear
you which might be better for everyone
but I just try to match these and hope
that it works out in proper way would
you like to have Gruden as your sidekick
doing a golf event nope the III thought
those would be the good announcer swaps
when I was at ESPN we did a college
basketball guys working with NBA guys
although the good announcer swaps would
be like have Gruden do an NBA game get
Hubie Brown to do a monday night
football game okay so what we have your
sister down all right third five what we
need here is to get into the painted
area and get the first down that would
be different that would be something
people would remember well if you got
Gruden he'd be like this guy this guy he
wouldn't know anybody would just say
this guy i love this now he would you
know John John is a big MBA fat john
loves the Celtics loves the selfish I
like to have him as a golf announcer
mike hoggard yeah music is a golf
watcher to me he'd be said you'd be
surprised he's actually a really a
really big sports fan this way these
guys are now you know that is become you
come across people but that would be fun
I know you know what he doesn't say that
nearly as much as claimed he does I bet
if you wish you would hear say that more
than once in a football game blame
Caliendo Bob of course saliendo is great
Caliendo did he didn't like me because
he couldn't get an imitation of me down
and it kind of hurt his whole gig but
what I think is greatly Caliendo can go
from like berman to stephen a smith to
Gruden ought to Ditka all in one fell
swoop yeah I target that's hard to do he
is he's very far I've seen him live his
show is terrific he didn't like he said
he couldn't get my voice down either oh
well you know i was wonder what I
haven't come with you it's not the hair
perhaps s ok and now we work at the same
place he's a mic Treecko no longer with
ESPN he now works for NBC Sports good
luck I hope that's in your
head throughout the weekend Mike I'm
glad to make it impressionable and I'll
see you to come it will be my pleasure
yeah if not it's my pleasure to buy you
dinner in Rio yes bout time thank you my
pal thanks Mike Tirico NBC Sports the
Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience